it is going to be interesting to see
what happens next like i have no idea
because
she is like happy with paxton and that's
happening officially right
are you here as my friend or is my
[Music]
damn baby you're gonna make me say it
[Music]
as your boyfriend i think the whole you
know past in realizing
what davey means to him is really nice
because he realizes like
this is the person that like believes in
me and doesn't think i'm stupid
and i actually accomplished something
and
she was there for me you know like i
think it's pax and setting aside like
the ego and the pride and also offering
forgiveness and being like okay
like this is the situation it's it's
really heartwarming
[Music]
so i guess i'm paxton hall yoshida's
girlfriend now
yes i guess so i wonder what that's
going to be like
i think it'll be a really cool to see
davey in like a proper relationship
because we technically never really have
right it was a two-timing situation and
as dr ryan and eleanor says
that doesn't count that's not real she
has zero boyfriends
so it is gonna be cool to see her as a
girlfriend
like that new relationship in her life
that she's never had before
the finale debbie ends up with paxton
they're with each other so jiren how do
you think this is going to impact
future seasons i think that it is
again we use the word messy and it's
messy now
i think that ben genuinely does have
these feelings for anissa i think that
his relationship with her was true and
it was strong
but at the same time you can't turn
those feelings off that's representative
of
high school and relationships at any age
you can't just all of a sudden stop
feeling things
i mean this is a tv right
like it's tv and uh if she were done
with ben
eleanor wouldn't have said what she said
which is like honestly one of my
favorite like parts when eleanor really
just
digs into him like you know for the
record it wasn't always him
like damn let him know let him know
of course i think ben is obviously gonna
still be
a player in the game are y'all surprised
do you think
this is actually going to work out are
you a fan of it
i'm i'm not mad at it honestly i'm like
i'm i'm here for it i feel like i feel
like it is going to work out i feel like
it's going to work out for a bit
really okay i feel like they're gonna
have issues for sure
right like drama yeah there's definitely
gonna be some drama but i feel like it's
gonna work out for a good bit
so i think that when he sees paxton and
davey so proudly defying this stereotype
that they can't be together
it hurts and i think that we see that on
his face and i don't think that he knows
how he was
he's gonna deal with that yet i think
that there's gonna be a lot of
processing
i there's so many different pathways
that he can go into
paxton guys how can you be so sure when
you're old and on your deathbed
whose naked body do you want to be
picturing wouldn't i be thinking about
my kids and
grandkids and stuff no that's a myth now
darren do you feel like debbie and uh
paxton are beyond their issues because
they do have some deep-rooted ones you
know a lot of ego's been hurt
on both sides so you know
i think it's high school and it's very
easy
to take an issue and bottle it but then
have it come out a whole
different way very shortly after um
yeah he was definitely hurt you know and
i think
davey also has a right to be heard as
well with how he responded to it
and this is all very much a
big dramatic wonderful culmination
or you know to to their
their troubles and i mean megan you on
the other hand
you got a little thing going on with
benny boo over there so i'm thinking
do i think ben's still into davey so i
don't know
he's got to make a pizza are you
supportive of paxton
and davey i feel like for on for
a niece's sake i almost have to be like
yes
go baby go with paxton leave ben alone
but also um yeah i also just feel like i
don't know then also
love yourself so like no anissa can do
better you know she doesn't have to be
with someone who doesn't want to pick
her
but yeah no i'm totally into this this
this whole love thing
but i don't know if they're done yet you
know it's easy to
you know walk into a dance with the
lights flashing and the music blaring
and feel like you have that movie moment
but the thing about movies they don't
show what happens after
i think that baby's putting a lot of
work to get this far
so to see it come around but come around
organically and have him realize what
he's missing out on
versus the latter love that what can we
expect for season three because there is
a dot dot dot at the end of this season
so when are you giving it to us and
mindy when are we going to see
you in an episode both are great
questions i mean we
love our our partners at netflix we hope
hope hope they want to pick us up for
another season that would be amazing
and so we're just going to wait and hope
keep our fingers crossed